c'est que rien de maximum qu'il n'avait
pu transporter c'est quoi cette question
38 40
et c'est vrai que tu m'avais c'est ainsi
c'est un signe une voix et jamais volé
peut-être par un saut de filles comme
moi et alors tu m'avais faire arrivera
rien c'est vrai j'ai pas soin de toi
très mal
j'arrive pas à croire que tu es heureuse
je prenais en plein jeu la cage toi il a
fait sortir jamais joué à ça j'écoute
moitié un rite mais bon
oui
de karine rosinski madame qui se passe
c'est quoi ce bon rester calmes monsieur
péter voser [ __ ] vous êtes karine
rosinski et ses voisins même si vous
précédents jours j'ai un mandat d'arrêt
au nom de karine rosinski c'est pas ici
vous vous trompez c'est pas elle mais
c'est votre cas vous le faites vologe
plus est ce que vous pouvez confirmer
votre identité c'est pas et je vous dis
de karine rosinski madoff rapporte quoi
c'est ma femme c'est la directrice de
l'école montée papier au nez cette
karine rosinski